[Music]
could you tell us
what you learned from steve jobs about
taking vacations how did steve jobs take
vacations
well
i don't know of all of his vacations i
know of the vacations he took
while we were we were together at apple
for for 10 years and
what was really happening was you know
steve would go on vacation and in my
early days there would be like yes he's
going on vacation it's great we're you
know we're not going to have to hear
from him for seven or 14 days or
whatever the case may be
well that dream
met reality and the reality was very
different it turned out that steve you
know he would go on vacation he would
usually vacation at one or two places
and he'd go to the same places all the
time that's what he liked and that's all
good
and
he would go silent for the first kind of
24-48 hours he would be gone he would be
in transit he would be with his family
what have you for those first 48 hours
you wouldn't hear anything maybe 72 but
somewhere right after that
you started getting calls wasn't emails
it was calls from steve and steve would
be on vacation and he would be pondering
where the next product the next
direction for apple new technologies
things he's reading he used that
vacation as a time to kind of
expand his thinking and get outside of
the apple
the day-to-day and the projects that we
all knew and loved or maybe there was a
couple of things to improve on the
projects we were working on but he would
start thinking about oh let's go buy a
music company or should we go and do
this other kind of product or what
technology will it take to do this
because he's also reading he's reading
or he's listening to others saying
different technologies so he would be
calling going you would be like google
for him you're like hey what is the
latest on this and you're like uh okay
steve here's what we know i don't know
that i can go get back to you it's like
oh let me know when you know send me an
email on that and then 15 minutes later
he might call back with a different idea
and so it was literally while he was on
vacation during
reasonable hours this wasn't
wasn't crazy hours but you might hear
from him on vacation five or six times
depending on what he was thinking about
at that time per day
could be as much as a maybe zero per day
but
sooner or later along that vacation he
would call you and like want to
brainstorm something or want a piece of
knowledge or want to know the latest
about something that was related to some
some idea he had in his head and so
you loved it because you got to talk to
him about all kinds of things that
weren't the day-to-day but at the other
times you were like okay steve you need
to be on vacation and then two is how
much work are we going to have when you
come back
besides the the incredible amount of
work we're already on top of or trying
to get on top of
so why did you lead with that and why
write
this this particular chapter because
flashing back again to our first
conversation which i encourage people to
read i'm going to try to not overlap too
much with that but
back at general magic
you had a certain let's say approach to
work which was sure high ball high
volume high intensity kind of 10 out of
10.
and
that seems to have have changed over
time and just for people who have no
idea what general magic is i just want
to say
and tell me if this is off base but it's
kind of like yoda worsky's dune in a
sense where if people don't understand
that that was an attempt at making dune
which failed
but the talent that was assembled
ended up being this incredible diaspora
of kind of technical
innovation that then spread all over the
place like geiger you know creating
alien and so on
so general magic was somewhat like that
i would say the genesis of a lot of
amazing careers it's a great analogy
yeah great analogy
so
why why did you lead with that story in
that chapter and why why even write that
chapter
for me i went through that personal
struggle
and i think a lot of people do of i need
to work
harder than everyone else and spend more
time working so i was working 80
100 110 hours a week kind of thing
because that's what i thought needed to
happen i thought i needed to prove
myself through the number of hours
through the amount of work that i could
get done
and i was also really passionate and
kind of like you know you're a kid in
the candy store like for me i'm a geek
right i'm like oh i can do this i can do
that and i get to work on this and the
more hours i got at there i could go and
work and learn
right from all of these great people
around me so i one thing i had to learn
how to do the work and the other one is
doing the work right and learning how to
do it at a professional level like my
heroes around me would do so there was a
lot of learning and you know when you go
to school you go to school but you're
also doing your studying and all the
other stuff so it it was a little bit
more than going to a university but your
first jobs are really like that you
spend a lot of time but you also start
to learn
how to be productive okay and what being
productive means and doing a great job
versus just being there a lot of hours
and so
that's where it all hit for me
i i will say this i will i was
undiagnosed add adhd at that time frame
i was in general magic and
ultimately a couple years later then i
actually figured out what was going on
so i was trying to do my work
and and perform at a professional level
learn the work and i had adhd across all
of it so if you know anything about
writing code
right writing code and being in the
details and if your mind's always going
oh my god it made everything harder
right so it was all of those things
compounded and so that that chapter is
really about here's where i was maybe
you're
experiencing a lot of this yourself and
here's where a more balanced approach
now it's not your typical work like
daily balance but here's a way to do it
to be high performing do amazing things
but to also give yourself
the right amount per day
as well as per year of time off
right and time to think and and realize
that
when you get to go away from a certain
activity you're doing every time you
might be actually be able to think about
it more clearly and come up with the
answers more clearly if you're away from
it as opposed to into it all the time
you